Today's 'Drew Gooder' is Sherina Jones
from Miami, Florida, who's making headlines
for her organization Village (FREE)DGE.
And she came up with a unique way to provide free meals
to Miami locals who have been struggling
through the pandemic.
And Sherina is here now.
I can't wait to meet her.
Hello.
Hi Drew, thank you so much for having me.
(audience clapping)
Oh my gosh Sherina, you're so beautiful inside and out.
Thank you.
I was so excited about this story
because when the pandemic first started
it was one of the things that I gravitated to most
was Community (Free)dges
And yours is very special.
Please tell us about it and when it started.
Village Free(dges) was founded in August of 2020.
The word Free(dge) is a combination
of the word fridge and free.
I wanted to combat the growing hunger,
the crisis in the community
because the pandemic had taken a toll on so many families.
So I just sat day and night, like what could I do to help?
So I took $180 of my own money
and I purchased the first community refrigerator.
And I got with business owners, my cousin,
Isaiah Thomas and Danny Agnew of Roots Collective.
And I asked them what they mind if I put a refrigerator
outside of their business and they agreed to do so.
So that's how this amazing initiative started
with two guys that agreed to put the refrigerator
outside their business.
And you also have a small business
that was impacted by the pandemic, right?
Yes, I am a full-time aesthetician, a Snob Beauty Box
which is my baby that I birthed eight years ago.
So I do beauty services on women,
eye lashes, makeup, skincare, and body waxing.
So in my remaining time outside
of running my full-time entrepreneurship job,
I take care of the community refrigerators.
I mean, well so many of us wanna try
to figure out what we can do.
You are out there doing it.
What do you try to put in your (FREE)DGES, may I ask.
Inside of the refrigerators,
we make sure we include water, canned goods,
sandwiches, bread, potatoes, frozen foods
that can be microwaved.
And we just don't accept anything that's opened
or half eaten and always be sure to check the dates
of things that are donated to the (FREE)DGE.
I mean, it just seems like in everything you do
whether it's your beautiful business as an aesthetician
or building your community Free(dges),
you're such a caretaker and so thoughtful
and thorough about everything you're saying.
And Drew Gooders like you, are just so important
to us here at the show but far more importantly,
the communities that they serve.
And we just wanted to tell you
that our friends at Omaha Steaks heard
about what you're doing
and they wanna send you $10,000
worth of single serve protein meals and steak stacks.
(audience cheering)
Thank you so much.
Sherina, you are such an inspiration.
I really mean it, when we sit there
and we think about all the things we can do.
I think the acting on it is the big difference
and the way that you follow through,
the example that you set
and the service and goodness and life-changing health
that you provide people,
were just on view here.
Really, thank you.
Thank you so much for having me.
Thank you to Sherina.
Thank you.
Okay, so for more information on how
you can help support the GoFundMe
for Village (FREE)DGE, (FREE)DGE
visit our website and we'd love to drive as much support
as we can to you Sherina.
Thank you for everything you're doing.
(audience clapping)
(upbeat music)